-Performing her hit
"Don't Know Why"
from "Come Away with Me"
20th Anniversary
Super Deluxe Edition,
please welcome Norah Jones!
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I waited 'til ♪
♪ I saw the sun ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't know why ♪
♪ I didn't come ♪
♪♪
♪ Left you by ♪
♪ The house of fun ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't know why ♪
♪ I didn't come ♪
♪♪
♪ When I saw ♪
♪ The break of day ♪
♪♪
♪ I wished that I ♪
♪ Could fly away ♪
♪♪
♪ Instead of kneeling ♪
♪ In the sand ♪
♪ Catching teardrops ♪
♪ In my hands ♪
♪ My heart is ♪
♪ Drenched in ♪
♪ Wine ♪
♪♪
♪ But you'll be ♪
♪ On my mind ♪
♪ Forever ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Out across ♪
♪ The endless sea ♪
♪♪
♪ I would die ♪
♪ In ecstasy ♪
♪♪
♪ But I'll be ♪
♪ A bag of bones ♪
♪♪
♪ Driving down ♪
♪ The road alone ♪
♪♪
♪ My heart is ♪
♪ Drenched in ♪
♪ Wine ♪
♪♪
♪ But you'll be ♪
♪ On my mind ♪
♪ Forever ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Something has ♪
♪ To make you run ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't know why ♪
♪ I didn't come ♪
♪♪
♪ I feel as empty ♪
♪ As a drum ♪
♪ I don't know why ♪
♪ I didn't come ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]